die
für corona haben wir keine zeit wir
müssen unsere kinder satt bekommen
irgendwann wird es sowieso jeden treffen
wie das morgenlicht wenn die sonne
aufgeht
das flüchtlingslager kasten 37 kilometer
nördlich der umkämpften stadt idlib
über eine million flüchtlinge leben in
der provinz die meisten in solchen
lagern
vor kurzem erst hat die korona pandemie
auch syrien erreicht
[Musik]
ihr wisst dass wir jetzt die ersten
corona fälle haben die sind die
zündschnur an einer bombe die jederzeit
explodieren kann
sollte das passieren wäre das eine
katastrophe unser gesundheitssystem ist
schwach einen großen ausbruch könnten
wir nicht beherrschen
im lager kasten leben 400 familien über
2200 menschen
caroline kam vor einem jahr mit seiner
familie im lager an
sie mussten fliehen als die bomben auch
ihr dorf erreichten nach verschiedenen
flucht stationen landeten sie
schließlich hier im kasten sein ältester
sohn starb vor zwei jahren bei einem
bombenangriff
seitdem müssen amado und seine frau
halima auch die vier kleinen enkel
kinder großziehen camaros jüngster sohn
ist erst 15 jahre alt und lebt noch bei
ihnen als der krieg begann musste ich
mit der schule gleich wieder aufhören
wir mussten fliehen
hier gibt es keine schulen in die ich
gehen könnte mein vater hat niemanden
der ihn unterstützt würde ich zur schule
gehen wer sollte ihnen helfen
früher hatten sie viel haben als bauern
ihr geld verdient doch das war in einem
anderen leben vor dem krieg hier in
karken grenzgebiet zur türkei im
flüchtlingslager klopft amadou steine
für den straßenbau und er sammelt müll
plastik und altmetall dass er
weiterverkauft so verdient er im schnitt
einen euro pro tag
mein mann geht plastik sammeln
ich habe ihm gesagt er soll nicht
rausgehen damit er sich und uns nicht
mit dem virus ansteckt aber er hört
einfach nicht alle anderen gehen zur
arbeit die leute aus der nachbarschaft
gehen müll sammeln also geht er auch ich
sage ihm er soll vorsichtig sein also
wäscht er sich die hände wenn er
zurückkommt wir machen die sache sauber
bevor wir sie sortieren damit wir nicht
das virus einfangen und wir halten das
plastik von den kindern fern sie dürfen
es nicht anfassen
habt ihr angst vor corinna wie sollten
wir keine angst davor haben das virus
ist kein spaß es tötet die kinder sind
noch so klein wenn sie alles anfassen
könnten sie sich leicht infizieren sie
sagen man wird davon krank und kann
davon sterben
ich sehe dass die leute trotzdem
arbeiten gehen also gehe ich auch ich
bin schließlich für die kinder
verantwortlich sie müssen ja irgendwie
überleben
ein syrischer arzt hatte seine familie
auf der türkischen seite der grenze
besucht und sich dort infiziert
nach seiner rückkehr wurde er am 9 juli
positiv auf das corona virus getestet
davor hatten alle angst und wussten doch
dass es irgendwann passieren wird die
syrische zivilschutzorganisation weiß
helme arbeitet hier im rebellengebiet in
der sogenannten befreiten zone das
krankenhaus in dem der erste corona fall
auftauchte wurde wochenlang unter
quarantäne gestellt es war ein herber
rückschlag denn immer wieder werden auch
krankenhäuser zum ziel von luftangriffen
des syrischen regimes und der
verbündeten russischen kräfte wir
brauchen jedes bett sagen die helfer
[Musik]
die menschen in nordsyrien sind durch
die korona krise in einer noch
schlechteren lage wegen der zustände in
den unterkünften die zelte schützen sie
nicht vor der sommerhitze und auch nicht
vor der kälte im winter wir weiter tun
was wir können sie vor der pandemie zu
schützen
die freiwilligen helfer machen
krankentransporte desinfizieren die
lager machen aufklärungskampagnen masken
tragen abstand halten händewaschen
doch die menschen leben dicht an dicht
viele gehören risikogruppen an
es ist fast ein wunder dass es bisher
noch keine große infektionswelle gegeben
hat durch spenden aus dem ausland kamen
anfang april die ersten testgeräte und
test materialien in die region idleb
seitdem können sie proben nehmen und
analysieren
nicht viele aber immerhin es ist eine
kriegswirtschaft und die menschen haben
gelernt auch in krisenzeiten zu
improvisieren
einige krankenhäuser mussten die unter
strenge quarantäne stellen niemand darf
rein weil das virus so gefährlich ist
wir wollen nicht dass es sich ausbreitet
würde das im norden syriens passieren
würde unsere krise noch viel viel größer
werden
sie sind abhängig von den
hilfslieferungen die über die grenze auf
der türkei ins land kommen doch das
regime in bagdad will verhindern dass
dadurch auch die oppositionsgruppen in
idlib versorgt werden
so sitzen die helfer und die flüchtlinge
zwischen den fronten
die vereinten nationen haben vor dem
assad-regime und russland kapituliert
beschwert sich abdul rasak hat er ist
für die logistik der hilfslieferungen
zuständig die un haben zugestimmt den
grenzübergang in kellys zu schließen und
nur den übergangen barbara hauer offen
zu lassen
schon vorher kam nicht genug rüber was
un un welternährungsprogramm geschickt
haben hat nicht mal ein viertel unseres
bedarfs gedeckt wie soll das jetzt mit
nur noch einem einzigen grenzübergang
funktionieren heißt der grenzübergang
auf der türkischen seite dieses nadelöhr
kann das assad-regime besser
kontrollieren
es war der kompromiss den die vereinten
nationen schließen mussten damit
überhaupt noch hilfe ins land kommt 711
kilometer grenzmauer hat die türkei
errichtet damit die flüchtlinge auf
syrischem gebiet bleiben
es soll nicht noch mehr kommen denn über
drei millionen syrer leben bereits im
nachbarland türkei
die türkische grenzstadt datei ist
zufluchtsort vieler syrer die es über
die grenze geschafft haben oft mit hilfe
von schleppern für sehr viel geld
nun hocken sie unter der straßenbrücke
im zentrum treffpunkt der tagelöhner
sie müssen ihre kassen wieder auffüllen
was sie vereint ist der traum weiter zu
ziehen
die türkei ist für die meisten nur
durchgangsstationen wir wollen nach
europa die armut hier bringt uns um es
gibt nicht genügend jobs wenn wir glück
haben finden wir beschäftigung an ein
zwei tagen pro woche
in europa gibt es sozialleistungen hier
gibt es für uns so etwas nicht in der
türkei bekommen wir keine
sozialleistungen und mit dem was wir
verdienen können wir uns gerade mal das
lebens wichtigste leisten
nahe der grenzstadt kellys treffen wir
mehmet aslan der unternehmer baut auf
seiner großen bio gemüse und obst an
in der region kellys leben heute mehr
syrer als türken
von den rund 150.000 einwohnern sind
über zwei drittel syrische flüchtlinge
auch die arbeiter auf janas lanz feldern
sind alle syrer
die leute hier haben kein problem damit
dreimal so viele syrer aufzunehmen und
der grund dafür ist dass viele hier
verwandtschaft auf der syrischen seite
haben wir pflegen lange
freundschaftliche beziehungen zu unseren
nachbarn einige teil mit ihnen ihr haus
andere sogar die bettdecke
nur so kann es funktionieren viele der
syrer waren früher selbst bauern hatten
eigene felder bevor sie aus ihrer heimat
flohen hier in der türkei sind sie
billige arbeitskräfte als landarbeiter
verdienen sie bei jan aslan zwischen 6
und 9 euro an einem zehn stunden tag
sehr viel weniger als ein türkischer
landarbeiter bekommt ballett ist 15 kam
mit sechs jahren über die grenze wie so
viele der arbeiter hier müsste er
eigentlich noch zur schule gehen
doch sie alle müssen geld verdienen um
ihre familien in syrien zu unterstützen
nach europa weiter ziehen wie so viele
andere bild khaleq nicht
[Musik]
ich denke ich bleibe in der türkei und
wenn sich die lage in syrien irgendwann
beruhigt dann gehe ich wieder zurück bis
dahin aber werden wir hier bleiben denn
wir haben uns an das leben hier gewöhnt
wir wollen nicht nach europa europa ist
eine andere eine neue welt ich habe dort
niemanden mit dem ich reden kann
wir kennen die kultur nicht aber hier
kennen wir sie in europa müsste ich zur
schule gehen und wurde dort kein wort
verstehen
der krieg in idlib ist nur ein paar
kilometer von hier entfernt wie es auf
der anderen seite aussieht das wissen
die menschen hier nur zu genau
drüben das sind ihre leute ihre familien
ihre freund informationen kennen keine
grenzen
sie verbreiten sich schnell so wissen
sie auch das in einem unscheinbaren
mietshaus im grenzort dreihundert hilfe
wartet im elfer rehabilitationszentrum
die frauen und kinder hier kamen alle
legal über die grenze mit einer
sondergenehmigung sie alle sind
schwerkrank warten hier auf behandlungen
oder lebenswichtige operationen die in
syrien nicht durchgeführt werden könnten
unser ziel ist es dass wir wieder bis zu
30 patienten täglich auf die türkische
seite holen können
ihr wisst was in idlib gerade passiert
und wie es dort aussieht
die leute dort könnten sich kein leben
in der türkei leisten könnten kein haus
mieten könnten nicht regelmäßig ins
krankenhaus das ist alles zu teuer also
geben wir ihnen unterkunft strom wasser
internet alles umsonst
und sie bekommen bei uns frühstück und
ein mittagessen fátima hat brustkrebs
sie kam für die untersuchung aus dem
lager bei idlib
ich habe vier kinder zwei jungen und
zwei mädchen
wir haben im lager alle in einem
einzigen zelt gelebt was soll ich sagen
wie es uns geht
es ist alles eine große tragödie ich bin
krank geworden wegen der schlimmen
zustände im flüchtlingslager
vorher war ich kaum krank aber im lager
da war nur müll und dreck das ist es was
wir dort durchmachen müssen
eicher ist mit ihrer tochter gekommen
ihre anderen kinder hat sie bei der
großmutter zurückgelassen
ihr billiger ölofen im lager explodierte
die tochter erlitt schwere verbrennungen
drei monate lang wurde sie in der türkei
behandelt dann mussten sie wieder zurück
konnten wegen des corona aus brust nicht
zur nachbehandlung kommen erst jetzt kam
der anruf
die tochter soll eine plastische
operation erhalten
er will wissen wie es ihren anderen
kindern im lager geht per handy erreicht
sie dort ihre mutter hallo wie geht es
euch was soll ich euch sagen die lage
ist im moment wirklich schlecht aber wir
können nichts machen hier bekommen wir
keine hilfe und wir haben kein geld gott
steh uns bei falls sie uns die kinder im
zelt zeigen will bricht das internet ab
zurück im flüchtlingslager kasten auf
der syrischen seite der grenze zurück
bei hammer.de wien und seiner familie
halima bereitet das frühstück sie schürt
das feuer mit ein paar plastiktüten die
hammer am frühen morgen gesammelt hat
für holzkohle reichte das geld nicht
das haben sie für die eier ausgegeben
immerhin sie müssen den tag nicht mit
leerem magen beginnen
und jetzt noch diese corona infektionen
als wäre alles nicht schon schlimm genug
der krieg der hunger die steigenden
preise
so ist das virus für sie weniger
bedrohlich als die schließung der
grenzübergänge aus der türkei als noch
drei grenzstellen offen waren haben wir
schon kaum etwas bekommen und alles war
sehr teuer
was aber soll jetzt passieren früher
haben wir alle ein zwei monate
nahrungsmittelrationen bekommen und
jetzt nichts werden wir kriegen ein
einziges tor wird nicht mal einen
kleinen teil der camps versorgen können
ich glaube ab jetzt wird es nicht mehr
geben 0
das kann nicht funktionieren ich hoffe
gott wird uns helfen und eröffnet die
grenzen wieder
wenn nicht werden wir hier alle sterben
ich liebe meine enkel mehr als meine
eigenen kinder sagt hammer
wir müssen sie beschützen müssen es
schaffen dass sie leben und lachen so
wie andere kinder auf der welt auf
[Musik]